all right Bob here we are in that great
corpus of prophetic poems that people
traditionally call second Isaiah it's
their major contribution although this
editing that we've looked at earlier in
the book is theirs as well we've we've
been talking let's just look in this
section right at chapter 40 itself
because so many themes of this great
corpus of second Isaiah come up here
chapter 40 begins with these words
comfort comfort if you look at the
Hebrew it's not just pocket of nouns
being thrown around it's not an
individual being asked to provide
comfort but it's a plural command plural
imperative in the Hebrew God is
commanding a group to provide comfort to
this community in exile in Babylonia who
are these agents of God who's who's
being addressed by these commands to be
honest I don't have a clue the tradition
the interpretive tradition long ago
recognized the problem which is masked
by most modern translations that don't
tell you anything about the plurals they
appear here and they appear later on in
these imperatives as well in the
wilderness prepare a way for the Lord
make straight in the desert a highway
for our God what we can say about it is
that more than one person is being
addressed here so this is a community of
some sort and various people have tried
to guess just who it might be the
simplest assumption I think is that it
is in fact the community of interpreters
it is the community of the second Isaiah
it is the people who treasure this text
and are trying to interpret it so
suddenly from being an object of
interpretation for the later community
the text has turned on the interpreters
and the interpreters are now the object
of address in the
text so whenever the community of faith
whether Jewish or Christian reads this
text it suddenly is speaking directly to
them in whatever time they find their
way do you think that this this
community that's to provide comfort in
the midst of the suffering of Exile is
it in some way identified with with the
remnant I asked because if you go back
we looked in a previous section at
chapter 12 chapters 10 to 12 of Isaiah
and there there's this prophetic
prophecy of a remnant being comforted by
God it certainly is and the more we read
through the chapter it becomes clear
that the community being addressed is
one that is close to being wiped out and
that certainly meets the definition of
the remnant so if we look at what the
people are being asked to do they are
supposed to speak to Jerusalem tenderly
and cry to her that she has served her
term notice the judicial language that's
being used here the this is being spoken
of as serving penalty for crime and
certainly that fits the definition of
how Israel understood its exile in
Babylon just as earlier Jerusalem and
Judah suffered because by means of the
Assyrian invasion for past sins they had
committed so also the people in exile
understand their present position in the
same light so they are understanding
their punishment in Babylon in exile in
just the same way the earlier community
understood its punishment at the hands
of the Assyrians so Assyrians
Babylonians in the way in which this
interpretive tradition moves they all
function in the same way do you think
that the the suffering can all be
accounted for as punishment I mean the
whole notion of the people of God
suffering I think is very relevant for
people's lives we all wonder why we
suffer it yeah it is and the remnant is
characterized repeatedly as suffering we
know
that earlier on being part of the
remnant does not exclude the community
that is part of the remnant from
undergoing the judgment it's a strange
kind of judge but it's almost as if they
suffer more than just the judgment
whatever is really suffering subtle
what's point and none of the
commentators seem to have a really good
explanation for that notice that it says
Jerusalem has paid her penalty she has
received from the Lord's hand double for
all her sin
that's been a problem two interpreters
they don't understand what that means
there is left over suffering that has
gone on which either has to be written
down as or understood as unjust
suffering
I mean God does get mad at Assyria for
way overextending the role of instrument
of judgment in the arrogance just takes
but again that makes the point they
there seems to be an appropriate amount
of judgment that goes along with every
sin and the point being made here very
subtly is Jerusalem seems to have
suffered more than that now we're going
to get some very explicit treatment of
that later on in chapters 52 and 53 yeah
with the servants so it may be that the
same understanding is operating here
that the extra suffering of Jerusalem is
for some other purpose that it is
perhaps redemptive for sin that the city
itself did not commit maybe I should
just say something about the servant
because it's going to take a little
getting yeasty there's this figure in
this central corpus of second Isaiah
that people call the servant of the Lord
or the suffering servant and
interpreters through the centuries have
just shaken their heads and spilled jar
after jar of ink trying to figure out
who this person is but certainly in
chapters in the great poem in chapters
52 and 53 this figure is suffering and
it's not because of any judgment due to
him but
on behalf of others is this kind of a
foreshadowing or the other is a
foreshadowing of this it's not exactly
clear but the two passages may inform
each other and the way they are
understanding the role of suffering in
the community itself it's interesting
that here you have these anonymous
voices crying out the first to prepare
the way of the Lord back to Zion to
return to Zion and then in verse 6 we
have this anonymous voice crying out and
in I answers this and the eye is
probably the Prophet whose response to
the voice is well what shall I cry and
then an excuse for not doing anything
all people are grass their constancy is
like the flower of the field the grass
withers the flower fades when the breath
of the Lord blows upon it surely the
people is grass yeah this is a
reflection of Isaiah's oracle during the
Assyrian crisis which talked about the
Assyrians coming through and the people
are going to be like the grass that
withers in the summer heat I think
that's very interesting and now it's the
Babylonians yeah well I mean there's
echoes of the prophets original call
when when Isaiah first encountered God
high and lifted up in the temple he was
asked to go on a mission and his
response was well I'm unclean and my
people are unclean there's no way here's
another another Jefferson same thing
along the same lines what is frail
humanity to do given how puny and mortal
and finite we are and that I think is
one of the central spiritual mysteries
and wonders of second Isaiah is that
it's the very frailty and finitude of
human beings that is the source of their
true strength because if you recognize
your frailty then you can channel this
Word of God that's working god's
purposes through history and essentially
that's what the Hebrew parallelism says
in verse 7 yeah people are grass grass
does wither
but parallel to that idea the flipside
of that idea is that the word of our God
stands forever and there's no way you
can stop it in the translation we're
using there are no quotation marks
around verse eight but this has got to
be the divine answer to the prophets
effort again as in chapter six of
escaping the divine commission what can
I do all flesh is grass and God's
response is yes indeed the grass withers
and the flower fades but the word of our
God will stand forever
the promise that has been made is going
to be fulfilled and there's nothing that
human beings can do about it this leads
directly to the Commission not to a
group but yet to another method
messenger and that is the personified
city of Jerusalem itself which has
suffered for its own Redemption and
that's going to raise a really
interesting question later on when we
begin to look at the idea of redemption
and what the Prophet understands by it
it's another one of those crucial themes
that pops up from time to time and
second Isaiah and we will look at that
in later sections